hey yo
chill out
chill out they even made the music sound
like indiana jones chill out i'm getting
wanda vision feels right now get out of
town
that's crawling
we're doing we're doing the jeff level
there is no b22 in bing bingo
it goes to 15.
wait a minute is that
it's just like
it's like everybody knows
what is happening why she's got the
scarab she literally has a blue scarf
is everything in this [ __ ]
why
what is reality
what is reality it's cupcakes
oh my god
nuts
i love it
[Laughter]
i can't even believe that they're
together right there's another one
is it jake
that one leave that one closed don't
is that you don't
oh is that the crate like the like the
murdery
i don't know
the right it's kind of true right who
else who else
could it be yo you guys are going to
chill out chill oh chill out
oh [ __ ]
ah
nah my god
that is the appropriate one
[Music]
[Applause]
what is happening oh tower head nice to
meet you damn my god holy what an ending
oh my god my mind is blown i
jesus christ i can't even believe this
man i don't know what i don't know my
brain i can't process it i don't know
what's happening so much to talk about
whatever discuss
welcome back to new rock stars the tomb
has been busted on me
and busting makes me feel good
my god steven's discovery of the
long-lost tube of alexander the great
might have been a plausibility step too
far and then a gunshot from arthur
harrow sends mark into a mysterious
sunken place mental hospital that now
has us questioning everything we have
seen on this series was this whole show
all in mark's mind or is this hospital
yet another delusion designed to make
mark think he is delusional
god damn it so many questions ah but my
favorite kind of questions right this is
inside marvel it's our weekly reaction
show to marvel's moon night i'm eric
voss my easter egg breakdown is going to
be on the channel later today but right
now i am reacting to this episode with
md
mt
thoughts bro i did not think i was going
to see any type of hungry hungry hippo
at any point during this episode
holy mole like what is happening
obviously like we're getting some type
of like jeff lemire vibes from this
because like this is very much in kid to
his run but like what is reality anymore
what is it i don't know
what was it ever what was wrong
it was like things from the beginning
we've had people uh like making fun of
us and dragging us in week one when
we're like no trust us there's like
weird stuff going on in this reality so
there's a bit of like vindication right
now to see the show
acknowledge the fact that like the
reality we've been seeing might be
surreal in some ways but i i don't think
they're doing that classic thing of like
it was all a dream no i think this was
this mental hospital is equally bizarre
and has all kinds of um legitimacy
issues in its own right so but i mean
this is how it feels to read the
greatest moon night comic runs you never
know yes what is real or not how much of
this proper moon knight that is that
like that is 100 moon night right there
it's like what is going on like you
cannot trust what you're seeing at all
at any point and i i love this twist so
much if anything i would have loved to
have gotten this twist a little bit
sooner in the moonlight series um just
because i think like the waiter you or
the waiter you late
the later you wait to uh to pull the rug
out from beneath our feet i think the
fact that moon knight has a series us
going into it knew that we're going to
be like looking at an unreliable
narrator
i i think that maybe you could end it
episode wonder episode two on on this
and then you could have dealt with the
ramifications after that and just lived
in that in that fun space i would have
yeah i would have rather gotten here way
sooner in my opinion yeah we've gotten
used to this this world of uh indiana
jones adventuring uh throughout these
first four episodes right so now that
we've gotten kind of used to that to to
pull that on us uh look i think every
great series needs to have a great twist
like that and i and i especially love uh
when that twist is like a descent into
the unknown into the depths of hell we
might be able to call this for the
underworld um but like uh
i think you could still have those beats
while just kind of revealing mark as an
unreliable narrator a bit sooner i think
great twists uh like come at the end of
a series you've already been enjoying
like every show you should watch you
should be enjoying the ride as you've
gone and you shouldn't be feeling like
what is this i'm frustrated i'm confused
and then the twist is like see that's
why you were frustrated and confused no
a great twist should make you love
something even more something that you
already love you should love it even
more
anyway but i it sounds like i'm hating
on the show right now no no no no really
great i really very much enjoy this
twist there were some moments in this
episode where i was like i don't know if
that uh really makes sense to me right
now i don't know if i'm enjoying what
i'm watching right now um but walking
out of this episode it all
gels together in this beautiful way here
in the mental hospital and i love this
so so much that they did this and i
think it's such a bold cool move that
they did this and i feel like it allows
like the other actors to like explore
like different
types of the different sides of their
roles rather and like just do this
because we see layla completely acting
not like layla at all i'm like oh i'm
not i bet you to see how this actress
portrays this side of layla now or this
like you know in this weird reality and
it makes the whole cast as an ensemble
have to do the work they all have to do
the research to understand uh what it is
like to uh go through uh like a
debilitating mental disorder right
you just have to explore
what it means physically and uh i mean
obviously bobby and billy they work his
orderlies here interestingly
harrow is basically still harrow you
know he's still playing his games but
there are some slight variations that
ethan hawk is playing there um when the
whole cast came out on the red carpet
and stood there together i'm like it's
interesting that even the b players like
billy and bobby are also standing up
there with oscar isaac and ethan hawk
but now it makes sense now they're very
much part of this and i just love this i
love that choice so much let's recap
what happens this episode so episode 4
of moon knight actually from the get-go
cranks up the indiana jones theatrics
really what i would say to crystal skull
levels of madness
it's at times a bit hard to watch what
is happening i i really enjoyed it
personally like in terms of like the
suspense like
in terms of like that the creepy like
stalking and all that stuff we really
don't really get that in like marvel
movies so like i was enjoying like wow
this is a mcu film i think this is
really interesting but like i i don't
even hey if you if it works for you if
it works for anybody watching this great
awesome awesome i think it's it's super
there are some really fun aspects to it
um it just totally seemed a little
mismatched for me in some moments and it
just lost me in some moments and but in
fairness by the end of the episode it
made perfect sense why they were doing
this and and i and i think it was all by
design uh to give credit to this show um
but this episode begins with like layla
managing to save her and steven's
unconscious body from an armed truck of
harrow's men yeah explore that old flare
in the open box of loose ammo trick
killing all of them but somehow managing
to avoid all that shrapnel hitting her
steven nice nice okay that was the only
part of the episode where i was like nah
she would she would have taken at least
one bullet like she would have gotten at
least a little bit empty there are some
other crazy things that happened this
episode i think it's okay i think it's
fine that those things happen uh
especially knowing the reveal we're
getting to um but uh so layla and steven
are able to track down harrow's camp and
it's empty uh they overlook the bloody
mummification tools that are just
scattered about there they share this
awkward kiss before they descend into
the tomb where uh ahmed sushapti is
buried with some mystery pharaoh who is
ahmed's final avatar now a lot of this i
loved how nerdy stephen was and also how
nerdy uh laila was there was an
interesting moment where she's like this
place must have cost a fortune like you
can see the fortune and glory kind of
glimmering in her eyes and stephen's
like uh-huh but yeah so all uh it also
needs to be in a museum
just kind of this interesting connection
between the two of them very sweet uh
very genuine um that what did you think
of the kiss what was your take on the
kisses
i mean hey um it's it was a very uh
awkward kiss but stephen grant is an
awkward guy so you know i guess i
thought it was perfect for steven
i just love at first like layla was
totally into it uh like she was ready to
make the move steve was like no no i
can't and then and then because later
and she's like
when you make the move it's not as good
you know my favorite part of the kiss
was after the kiss when mark was like so
you kissed her huh
i'm gonna have to fight you
with uh violence sorry that's my wife
you chose violence so down in this tomb
they realize this one chamber is in the
shape of the eye of horus and they
described it as a maze and then he like
drew it on this really cool texture that
reflected it to the ceiling but i guess
my question was like is this a maze it
kind of just looks like you drew the
shape of an eye of horus like a crop
circle but i don't understand how that
was a maze like how that was like a
six-way path like there's some points of
the maze where it splits off into three
or four different vectors i just didn't
understand how this shape was exactly a
maze and where in those lines of the eye
of horus they actually were i needed the
kind of legend of the map like you are
here in the eye of horse you just kind
of drew the shape of the i a horse and i
don't understand how looking around the
surfaces of that room they were like oh
yes the eye of horus like you would need
to be able to like go down each path and
then like
chart that out based on your steps and
they didn't do that they just kind of
walked around the inner chamber of this
room anyway it was kind of that's just
my little gripe of that moment like i
understand how they derived the eye of
horus from where they were staring out
standing i'm sure some of you in the
comments will be like well clearly they
did this i'm like i'm just telling you
i've watched this episode or this
particular scene several times and i
don't understand how they arrive but
anyway
um they then find this a mummification
room with fresh blood on the slab which
is an interesting moment of dread
they're like the blood should be dried
yeah at this point
someone's out here killing
actively killing uh and then uh we find
out there's this this creepy ghoul of a
zombie priest an undead priest who is a
buried with the pharaoh who's alive once
more and is now uh killing off harrow's
men just in the background in the
distance here's some gunfire and then he
drags the guy in there and just starts
extracting his organs as one does
casually uh you don't need those this is
the moment where like
i mean if you if you were genuinely
creeped out by all of this this stuff
with this guy like chasing them around
uh cool great awesome it worked for you
for me it lost me a little bit just a
little bit it just seemed like a little
tonally just a bit too goofy for me the
clicking it just felt like you know
after school episode of goosebumps as
opposed to like true creepy horror i
think the character design was just a
little too silly for me i think the
clicking was just a little too silly it
just didn't work it didn't work for me i
feel i feel like maybe because this is
disney plus and like because we know
that like disney plus is like you know
having like these weird like sensory
type stuff with their marvel stills i
think they don't want to cross a line
and make it too creepy for the kids uh
which is but i don't get it like we saw
so much blood all the people that he
killed in that town square in germany in
episode one it was way darker
to that level of like even when wanda
walks in to agatha's basement episode
seven of wanda vision there was some
genuinely
scary imagery there right you're just
kind of creepily walking in it's silent
and you don't really know what you're
looking at you just see piece by piece
like i didn't get that here
there weren't really any jump scares
here it just seemed kind of like just
seemed a bit silly i i don't know like
you would know better than me because
like i i avoid scary content so like you
probably watch a lot more scary stuff
than me so you would probably know
honestly like
i mean uh i might just be being a bit
too critical of it uh and again i i'm
fully aware that i think this was meant
to be a vhs directive video release kind
of thing and we're meant to kind of see
this as a bit like artificial and i
think that was by design i just think
like again when you're doing great
mystery filmmaking and in television
production like you're still meant to
enjoy the ride while you're on it you're
not meant to see the strings as you've
seen it and then later they tell you
that the facade you saw was actually
this and then you're like oh i love it
even more now it's not meant to be like
i don't get it i don't get it i don't
get it oh that's why i didn't get it
like then it's like
it's it's less of a catharsis anyway um
but if it worked for you great i
understand that being pretty critical
here um but there's like a there's a
trust me there's an intent behind the
criticism because i think it makes me
appreciate the final scene of this
episode even even more yeah and like i
don't think you're being overcrowded
like this is a reaction episode so like
you're just reacting to what we saw man
yeah totally fine i'm telling you i
trust me i overall love this series and
i love the way this episode ended um but
uh layla manages to defeat the zombie
priest again she uses her go-to weapon
of a player to do it which i don't know
good old trusty
she uses light to destroy the darkness
however you wanna i hope she becomes the
flare-up the flare scarum
um so in this moment hero tells uh layla
that mark was there for the killing of
her father i guess he saw this when he
scanned stephens
meanwhile stephen finds the freaking
sarcophagus so happy for him
he just wanted to work at the museum and
now he's inside the tube of alexander
the great he moved on up
dreams now this is crazy that the
alexander the great tube shows up here
um but again this might all be
fictitious i understand that uh but i i
do love when the mcu intersects with
history and he uses the mcu to explain
long-lost history's mysteries but you
know there's like history channel people
are watching this like what no
but
what do you mean history channel is
always airing alien content now this is
right up there you're right you're right
you're right exactly that's a very good
point empty but there it does present
all these fascinating questions about uh
could alexander the great have conquered
all the lands that he conquered because
he had ahmed's backup is that what was
really going on there uh we'll talk
about that a bit more later but uh alex
inside of alexander's gullet he finds
ahmed sushapti and then laila confronts
him about her father mark confesses that
he was there for it but it wasn't him
who did it it was his greedy partner who
uh who killed all those archaeologists
he ended up getting shot uh and that led
to what you know how mark needed to go
to the statue and got possessed by
consho something we'll probably see
either next episode or episode six um
but this ends with harrow shooting mark
and the mark falls backward into a pool
of water but then mark descends deeper
and deeper into that pool you dropped
like uh
what's it called what was that horror
movie uh jordan peele's movie what
get out yeah it's like get out of sunken
place same kind of imagery yeah
absolutely um and then we find ourselves
watching this knock off indiana jones
direct-to-video release called tomb
buster
uh starring this archaeologist hero the
character named dr stephen grant and
this plays in a mental hospital tv
screen that is filled with everybody
we've seen on the show we see crawley in
there i think that was dylan sitting
there bobby and billy uh donna and the
forger and layla and mark this place all
over scene by harrow now i guess the uh
head psycho analyst of this place uh all
the props and stuff decorations we see
are all analog so things we've seen in
past episodes we saw the cupcake cart
the rubik's cube uh a plush scarab a
drawing of a hummingbird with concho's
head on it a goldfish on a stack of
books postcards uh moon knight action
figure so uh mark who is heavily
medicated is uh brought before harrow
and harrow talks cryptically about us
living not in a material world but a
psychic world
and suggests that mark might have
invented his other reality while
watching this tomb buster movie harrah's
office itself is designed like a wild
museum filled with egyptian artifacts a
painting of the alps setting from
episode one this does not look like a
normal head office of a museum
psychoanalyst what are you talking about
that's totally fine
yeah this is how it looks i'm sure um a
lot of sharp objects just laying around
but again by design by design uh mark
escapes the mental hospital itself just
begins to sway right and i love the
lamps just swaying like scales of
justice mark finds a room with a
sarcophagus containing steven these two
hug
so cool i love that moment they get to
hug and i love that they hug it's
supposed to fight you know that's it's
great it's like oh you kissed my wife ah
it doesn't matter let me hug you that's
that's the good friendship that's
brotherhood and then uh so they they
creep down the hallway mark sees another
sarcophagus gradle in another room they
don't look into it uh but it's probably
gonna be jake we'll see
then the doors swing open and we meet
towerette yes this is the hippopotamus
goddess of fertility in greek mythology
and she agrees i'm just going hi
which is terrifying i'm nervous too
and the markets even scream and i love
that they are most scared by the
sweetest
goddess
uh presented on this show khan shu yeah
kanchi made uh steven scream but mark
doesn't seem too afraid mark's like it's
got you bird skeleton you see it
sometimes it happens hippopotamus no yo
to be fair hippos are vicious
vicious
they will kill you
hippos are incredibly dangerous yes but
in this moment she's so sweet she's very
nice
this is obviously one of the biggest
what the fish moments in the mcu ever it
very much reminds us of the post-credits
scene to loki episode 4 when loki wakes
up in the void to meet gator loki you
know we just there's a bit of a formula
they're following here so empty and i
are going to do our best to explain what
is going on in this ending where mark
and stephen are who the hippo lady is
how much of this episode how much of
this series is objectively real uh but
before we get to that we are selling out
pretty fast of our uh latest thank you
so inspired by moon knight
thank you so much for all your support
this is tomb of the moon god we've had a
latest obsession shirt for each disney
plus marvel and star wars series and
some folks are collecting them all and i
think that's so amazing that you're
doing that when you buy one of these
shirts at newrockstarsmerch.com you'll
also unlock the ability to buy a custom
shout out that will run during our
inside marvel after shows like this one
justin says osiris is colluding with
harrow he is the god of death on it his
tool
it's why he ends the trial so fast
justin you might be on to something i
honestly feel like that members are
yeah they are definitely pro-amit in
ways that they should not be pro amit i
feel like set i think i feel like the
god set is is doing something because
where's that we have nothing of chaos
right yeah yeah oh good point good point
mti yeah i think these uh
i think ahmet might actually i think the
indiana has a secret these five there's
only five of them right now what do they
do the other four why do they promote
hawthor to it and include horrors
normally horses and on it so like yeah
there's a lot of vacancies and i think
it's just like what if the supreme court
basically like banished four of its
members and then brought in a form a
couple more to fill in the gaps actually
they banished like six of these members
and then brought in two others so like
there was a majority that was overruled
by three of them and then yeah so i
think yeah for sure um joseph asked
which identity would you choose if you
had the choice of one
um well i think stephen
i would pick steve no i would choose
mark because like just og mark because
like i just feel like steven is too
goofy too goofy um and yeah i don't know
like he's nice but like that dude he
just he has no game at all but then
again that's me
stevie's just me
accidental game with with layla you know
this is true mark's just kind of a jerk
i think late i think yeah mark is like
nerdy bumbling around a museum that's
that's the life i want to live and then
uh stephen fey said eric and mt when you
go to sleep at night do your other
identity scour shows for clues you're
amazing well thank you stephen very nice
of you to say i don't know about umc but
i have started to have a lot of stress
work dreams like uh like waking up in
the middle uh like in my dream i'm
waking up to think that there's like a
trailer that drops
and honestly when the thor eleven
thunder trailer dropped my mind woke me
up i checked my clock and i just didn't
happen to open like youtube and twitter
yeah but i looked at my clock and went
back to bed for like a half hour the
second i woke up no alarm woke me up i
woke up the second or at least the
minute that the thor love and thunder
trailer you know what i don't mean to
sound spiritual but i think that was the
god thor speaking to you to wake up he
said wake up wake up eric wake up
it's here
and instead i just looked at my phone i
saw it was like 7 30 because i had
already woken up at like 6 30 thinking
that like oh the trailer will drop east
coast time if it does drop today uh and
then i went back to bed but for whatever
reason i just checked 7 30 and i'm like
oh i'll check again at eight when i my
alarm goes off and i did check it out
late when at eight when my alarm went
off and i saw that it was like a ton of
notifications like oh crap i gotta jump
to work uh but it's just so weird how
long you got a spidey
internal there's a spidey yeah if we
push you out of your body doctor strange
style we're gonna see some squigglies
all right what's our question for this
episode mt alright homie what the fish
just happened in the ending of moon
night episode 4 because why do we have
hippopotamus ladies in a hospital that's
weird right and what is this hospital
for sure well from the get-go we gotta
say this series is both calling into
question mark and steven's whole
experience as a possible delusion as uh
as you know the moon knight comics do
especially the more recent runs by
writers like jeff lemire but this
episode is not firmly stating that
everything we have seen is in mark and
steven's mind
this may be similar to twists in fight
club or at the end of uh the wizard of
oz right but apologies to biggie this
was not all a dream as uh at least i
didn't see one word up magazine anywhere
i scoured it
um as silly as things have been or have
gotten in the normal world of moon night
things down here in the mental hospital
are even more surreal like if the show
wanted to do one of those classic twists
of it was all a dream the mental
hospital would just be a bear sanitized
completely plain political setting
instead this mental hospital is unlike
any mental hospital that exists in real
life we got cupcake carts we got bingo
with uh nonsensical numbers you would
never have b 22 and bingo it only goes 1
to 15 for b uh harrow's bizarre museum
office we got sarcophagi we got hippo
goddesses
this this place is obviously designed to
be a nightmare this is gothika folks um
i can't believe i referenced gothica um
halle berry is like just woke up
somewhere and be like
my ears are burning but we should be
mentioning
rather than gothica because of uh i
think so um i think in both realities
both inside the hospital the end of the
episode and everything pre-hospital are
equally surreal the scales of ahmed's
justice have just balanced out perfectly
uh and i think both of these should be
equally questioned they are equally
dubious realities so it was not all fake
it was not all a dream everything is
important everything is actually
happening to these characters yes um and
so let's talk about uh the hippo lady
the final image we meet tower it yes uh
this is the egyptian goddess of
fertility so uh yes and she takes the
form of a hippopotamus normally it's a
head of a hippopotamus and got some some
lady
some lady jugs but they ain't showing
that on disney place
they covered her up smart move
smart move um but uh is terroret uh what
tyrande why would she be so important to
mark and steven as a goddess of
fertility
fertility issues are not thematically
what mark and steven are about well if
you go back to the opening image of the
episode very very important because we
see osiris's avatar placing conscious
shabti among several other ushapti and
these might look familiar to you because
we have seen all these other shopkees in
the closing credits of every episode and
one of them in the closing credits on
brad winterbomb's uh title slide is
clearly towerette so that tells us that
tauret is one of the many deities who
have been imprisoned in some stone state
and in episodes five and six we're
probably going to meet all the other
physical forms of like konchu of amit
uh everyone else who was statueized and
the fact that we were seeing tauret now
in physical form suggests that mark and
stephen and that third altar and the
unopened sarcophagus were thinking we're
thinking jake all those guys now occupy
the same realm where the other banished
deities are exiled and i believe this
mental hospital is how mark and stephen
manifest the egyptian underworld i think
this hospital is the duat i think it's
the opposite of the overvoid we the
other five members of the ine ad go back
to that tomb busters line that hero
quotes spoken by the movie's villain no
tree can ascend to the light of heaven
if it doesn't descend to the depths of
hell to me that says it all i think we
are now currently in the depths of hell
and that's why we entered this hospital
by showing mark sinking into a sunken
place sinking into deep water going
deeper and deeper and deeper even though
the pool that he fell back to in that
tomb was just a few inches deep and when
he descended if you look closely the
bullet holes in his chest have vanished
so i think we are seeing his soul
descending into the underworld and uh
maybe it's just because it's thor eleven
thunder week i can't help but connect
that to this tree going from heaven to
hell to the depictions of utrecil the
world's tree of asgardian mythology
which extends upward into the heavens
but also downwards into the underworld
uh the snake
uh the dirt snakes surrounding the the
median of that mm-hmm
it might just be drawing a parallel two
yes the great yorman gander right i
think that's a great
serpent don't know i could never
pronounce nor snakes i know i shouldn't
even try i think it's completely valid
to get metaphorical with this and then
reframe mark and steven's entire journey
on this series as a soul passing through
the field of reads facing judgment and
now we are at the step of the hero's
journey where the hero descends into the
pit of despair into the depths of hell
and now for the final act must fight his
way back out of hell imagine the story
of orpheus in mythology right like you
have to climb your way out of hell don't
turn around and look at your loved one
because she'll disappear and should be
dragged back away from you and then you
you run you run through the
you run through the office building
while morpheus and uh not morpheus
then you went through the office
building while neo and trinity are in
the helicopter waiting for you to jump
and uh yeah it's the story of orpheus um
i watched that one it's pretty good
i mean
you bring it up but mt you were totally
right the third act of the matrix when
neo and trinity have to go back into the
matrix to free uh morpheus is the same
story it's like go you have to go into
hell and fight your way that kind of
health true every classic heroes
campbellian monomyth follows these steps
um now i don't know if i don't know how
literal or metaphorical the series will
be when it comes to what mark will
physically face right uh is this going
to be just like the metaphorical
analysis we apply to this or is it gonna
be like a literal fight uh is he gonna
have to fight his way out of uh this
underworld um are we gonna see him face
some kind of final judgment um is this
like a literal is it gonna be described
in the show you have you're literally
going through this process you've been
passing through the field of reads and
we've been judging you and when we tried
to judge you in episode one you were not
ready to be judged um i love looking at
the show that way because it's it's very
similar to what we saw in one division
in loki right
as we broke into the third act of vision
was right when wanda went into agatha's
dungeon that was her pit of despair that
was her hell for the purposes of
westview's structure for loki uh the
ending of episode four he went into the
void and the final two episodes were him
going into that hell and then fighting
his way back out of that hell
um now every episode of loki kind of
changed the game board in a certain way
but that in terms of the structure of
the series that's that's the steps you
go through um
so we'll see how literal this is but the
question mt and i should really talk
about first is was this underworld
intentionally designed by some external
force like amit using it to manipulate
and torture mark with projections from
his life like harrow and layla or could
have been designed by mark himself or
one of his altars to help him make sense
of all this
or is it all just incidental
subconscious projections from mark and
steven's minds
their own inner self doubt unconsciously
manifesting in these forms just
independent from anyone's control or
intent this is just how his like his
mind is just kind of piecing it all
together and no one's trying to torture
him or do you think that like ahmet in
this moment is like oh welcome to the
underworld
welcome to hell
you kill her
how do you see this empty what do you
think
i think that there be shenanigans a foot
my friend okay um because uh just
because of like the i've been googling
stuff on taware a lot and like tarared
is frequently mistaken for the goddess
ahmet because of their just because of
how physically similar that they look
because ahmed has the head of a a
crocodile well whereas she has the head
of a hippopotamus and like they and like
they also have like similar body
structures with like all that stuff and
we do and then you did mention that she
was the goddess of fertility but she's
also the goddess of like protection she
was like a protective god if i'm not
mistaken anyway so i think that we're
seeing like uh a mishmash of everything
that you just described there like all
those options because i think that
tarare is is trying to heal mark um in
more than one way she's probably just
healing the bullet holes but also we're
we're going into mark's mind everything
we're seeing in my opinion is cerebral
and that you know tarare is like sort of
in his head and being like hey this is
sort of your hospital you made this
because like and like you have to
remember that steven grant was looking
through that pamphlet earlier in episode
one after episode two rather um when he
got fired and like that pamphlet had all
that really neat um imagery of a
hospital i got some sort of similar
environment that he's currently now in
so like i think that he took that
information and he's he made that
hospital from his from his mind and sort
of like mismatched his own favorite
hobbies his his egyptian love so like
that's why the walls are sort of like
sort of egyptian-y and all that stuff
and so i think that
for some reason
torwaritz ushapti was carved to look
like um ahmet and that someone is
playing games someone said is set harrow
up someone like is trying to fake
ahmed's death or something and i think
that's where already just like hey
thanks for picking me up i'm going to
heal you now and like in the next
episode's probably going to be like like
you said with um long division i like it
how you made that one division illusion
because um we saw we had that episode
where sort of like a clip episode of
like the past um and so we're probably
gonna work through
mark's
like his illness and like sort of
visually see how that manifests through
this hospital um analogy but that's this
wild theory that i it could be anything
i don't know you're saying you're saying
to it i've been saying tower it um i
think you were just giving the other
alternate in case i have no wrong
pictures between t and i one of us is
right one of us is wrong or maybe we're
both wrong but um these are also like
ancient egyptians well he's it was
mentioned in episode one um um steve
does say it in a very weird way when he
mentions when he picks up the uh the
hippos for um i forget her name right
now uh for his mean boss
donna terrible donna you're so mean um
so he says like he's like it's a with it
he says tower it or something like that
i don't know he says it yeah but she is
mentioned in episode one okay so there
you go i think um uh i think you bring
up some very interesting points here
especially with that pamphlet empty uh
to my
here's what i'm going to say uh i think
there is an underworld in the mcu and i
think it was real
i think hell is real but it's probably
not going to be called hell and i think
if you have some kind of linkage with a
particular
deity figure
when you die you go to this other realm
i think for wakandan specifically
t'challa that realm manifested as the
ancestral plane right uh i think uh for
asgardians when they die they go to some
other similar realm obviously valhalla
or something like that when thanos
snapped in that moment he went inside
the soul stone and entered this other
ethereal plane i think
for if you have kind of reached this god
status
you
you go to this other ethereal plane and
that plane takes a different form uh
drawn subjectively from the enterer of
that plane in this case because stephen
and mark have had this connection with
konshu
i think when they die or when they're
close to dying that brings them to this
egyptian underworld and for
mark and for steven that takes the form
of a mental hospital i don't think
either of them are doing that
intentionally
i just think that's that's
subconsciously the what the walls look
like in the same way that when t'challa
enters the ancestral plane i don't think
he's deciding to make it look like a a
savannah with a tree with pancreas
because killmonger's was different
that's part of his soul that's part of
like uh his ancestral lineage and i
think for steven as someone with
dissociative identity disorder his soul
manifests it
uh in this form right and when thanos as
someone who's just like empty uh you
know he's wiped everything away for him
the soul stone looks like this just that
one gateway of his daughter with his
young daughter gamora um so i think
that's what this is i think when you
have this this godly connection and
you're in the marvel cinematic universe
when you're dying or close to dying or
close to dead or in this gradual process
of dying you enter this uh this ethereal
realm and it goes by many names maybe
one of those names might be the quantum
realm i mean maybe
uh and then this is just what it looks
like for each person uh there's a lot of
uh theological and spiritual discussions
that what is hell you know what will
hell look like or what will the
afterlife look like and there's all
these discussions and beliefs that
maybe hell just looks like something
different for each person uh the
the french existentialists sart
had this great line from no exit a play
that he wrote um famously hell is other
people um and
your hell might be where you live right
now but that seemed so applicable for
what mark was going through in this
mental hospital that his hell was the
other people of his life and him
realizing he did not know them like he
thought he did
i i read a really interesting quote that
said um hell was actually minute 42 of
morbius
sorry
was that quote written down in your own
notebook empty
it was yeah i was writing it during the
files watching movies
oh sorry oh my god sorry morbius it's
fine
um i think we've done a pretty good job
giving our best analysis of what we're
seeing in these final minutes obviously
there's plenty of ways to interpret this
i'm not gonna say any one way is right
or wrong we'll find out in future
episodes but at least this is the way
that gives me the most meaning for
what stephen and mark have been going
through these past four episodes and and
where they will go next um so we have a
several other questions we're going to
talk about this episode but first we
want to thank some people helped us make
this episode thank you to brooklyn and
for sponsoring this episode we all need
sleep and we all deserve comfortable
bedding enter brooklyn in one of the
internet's favorite sheets brooklyn and
was created in 2014 to give customers
luxury hotel level home essentials that
don't break the bank they offer
everything from snuggly sheets to cozy
towels and robes loungewear accessories
and much more by working directly with
the suppliers brooklyn and passes
savings back to their customers so you
can get their incredible products at a
reasonable cost first time trying
brooklyn don't worry their best-selling
luxe sheets are the perfect place to
start featuring an irresistibly soft
feel and buttery smooth finish brooklyn
launches new products colors and
patterns all the time for their sheets
towels and robes with some limited
edition collections selling out quick
you can also take brooklyn and signature
softness outside the home with their
loungewear collection featuring their
softest tees tanks sweatshirts joggers
and other essential basics and if you
need the extra nudge check out the 5
star reviews over 100 000 of them and
for a limited time brooklyn is offering
a free gift with purchase if you miss
out you can use the promo code inside
marvel anytime for 20 off your purchase
of 100 or more at brooklyn.com that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and enter the promo code inside marvel
for 20
off your first purchase today brook
linen the curators of comfort we also
want to thank helix sleep for sponsoring
this episode even if you have magical
armor that appears out of nowhere to
help you fight crime you still need a
good night's sleep on a mattress made
just for you our friends at helix
mattress are here to make sure you have
that felix sleep is a quiz that matches
your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers i
have a helix mattress and i love it mt's
mattress you love your mattress yes so
much like i
i honestly genuinely do guys i like it's
lit i've never had better sleep in my
life or at least as an adult like it's
so good please look into it um the
mattress ships right to your door for
free no need to go to a mattress store
just go to helixsleep.com inside marvel
take their two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up or if you don't love it but you're
going to love it helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com insidemarvel and we want
to thank story worth for sponsoring this
episode ever flip through your mom's
high school yearbook or your grandma's
old photo album and realize that they're
just huge portions of their life that
you don't know anything about that's
what happened to our researcher anna
recently and that's why she got her
mom's story worth story worth is an
online service that helps you and your
loved ones connect through sharing
stories and memories and preserves them
for years to come every week story worth
emails your mom a thought-provoking
question of your choice from a vast pool
of possible options each unique prompt
to ask questions you've never thought of
like what's some of the best advice your
mother gave you or if you were to do it
all over what would you do differently
it's just a really cool process for your
mom or your grandmother to reflect back
on their lives and share their stories
and it's just cool for you and your
family to learn more about them after
one year story worth compiles all of
those questions and stories including
photos
into a beautiful keepsake book the whole
family can share for generations give
all the moms in your life a meaningful
gift you'll both cherish for years story
worth right now for a limited time
you'll save ten dollars on your first
purchase when you go to storyworth.com
marvel that's
s-t-o-r-y-w-o-r-t-h dot com slash marvel
to save ten dollars on your first
purchase story worth dot com slash
marvel all right mt i wanna ask you
could anyone else other than jake be in
that other sarcophagus
[Music]
i think it was jake from state farm just
kidding no um maybe i think that
it's just highly likely jake because we
haven't seen jake yet and jake is a huge
part of the you know one of a huge altar
of in on mark spector's life so it's
it's got to be jake if there's a it's a
huge implication that it's jake um i
know i think you're right i think it's
most like like almost 90 shake but i'm
just like pl gonna uh think of the outs
right now
i i wonder if like
this show might really go oh
take a huge leap of faith and suggest
that maybe layla could be one of mark's
altars
i think that's a wild theory but it
would be just nuts to have someone who
is not jake not another isaac pop out of
that uh sarcophagus that would be um i
wonder if that could be where amit is
kept right now like it's buried
somewhere down there or consue is it
going to break out of there that is a
really interesting idea obviously like
you know this is just a fictional take
on what d.i.d is like we're not saying
that this is like d.i.d makes you like
avatar vomit this is just obviously like
a fictional take on that just so people
know because i know some people like oh
no
they're they don't understand what the
idea is we're just we're talking about
pictures right yes
i understand that i'm just saying like
the show has obviously stretched exactly
exactly
marcus now a delusional person people
suffering from did are not necessarily
delusional but the show is obviously
saying that this character is delusional
and suffering from certain kind of
delusions right at least in this episode
um i think it'd be interesting uh pretty
uh wild if like doctor strange popped
out of that sarcophagus
if he's just like hey i'm not one of
your alters but i am in here right now
i'm trying to save you
[Laughter]
um there's all kinds of fun uh cameos
that could pop out of that sarcophagus
so i'm just i'm just keeping my options
open for now um okay big detail major
detail layla on that bandage on her
finger a red scarab there's been a lot
of speculation that her name abdallah
al-fawali could be like abdul of el you
know the the scarlet scarab from the
early early invaders comics with like
union jack and cap and bucky uh a
protector of egypt who's presented as a
villain in that series but in our
historical looking back was just
protecting his homelands and every right
to protect his uh homelands from a group
called the invaders so could layla
become the mcu's scarlet scarab is that
what this is i would really hope so i
think it'd be really cool to see layla
you know just become a like a really
kick-ass character in the mcu though i
have this weird feeling that layla might
be connected to
the goddess neptus and this is just my
weird theory um because i i have a
feeling that konchu
misses someone and you know we know that
the moon he's the god of the moon and
the moon is always around at night and
neptus is the goddess of night and so i
have this weird feeling that layla might
be linked to her but
you know the scarlets we do have that
scarlet scarab and like that is
too much of a coincidence and like given
like what people it's not even red that
is straight up scarlet that is straight
up scarlet that is a scarlet scarab so i
would hope that this isn't just marvel
just playing with us like they played
with us with those little mephisto
teases in uh
in no way home i think i hope that's not
a misdirect and it's actually we're
gonna see layla to kick some ass okay
another question i had alexander the
great
now this may be uh just part of this uh
fictitious reality right but if they
establish that this is like
real that much is real
could alexander the great or is the show
saying that alexander the great was so
great because he had ahmed's help what
do you think empty i think that's the
implication i think that you know
he's this huge historical figure and he
was great he was like one of the
greatest like conquerors of all time and
so like you know he and he did all of
that before he was like 30. so like yeah
that's what made him such a prodigy is
that he accomplished so much when he's
so young at a young age so i think that
the mcu is implying that like yeah it's
kind of it's highly unlikely for someone
to do that without some type of help so
i think that yeah ahmed was uh his or
whoever he had a godly assistance yeah i
think 100 i think that's the idea i i
would love to see uh just a breakdown of
everything alexander the great uh
accomplished mm-hmm at his young age uh
and just say like ahmed helped out with
this um
uh great news for you uh because me and
brandon
we we thinking about talking about that
very soon my friend
upcoming big question maybe yes i can't
wait to see it
all right as we look ahead to next
episode mt mark and steven and perhaps
jake are in this mental hospital i
assume they're going to be fighting
their way out of it yeah how do they get
out and can they escape this hospital um
very simple solution um i hear all you
have to say is blues could do we can too
and uh they're out
instantaneously
i wish um but no i i think that
um just just um just judging by like the
themes that i'm seeing in the show
especially with the goldfish i think
that there's a theme of
like
repairing yourself and like trying to
accept yourself and become whole and
like we at the beginning we see that
this goldfish has one fin and like at
the beginning we know that mark spector
and steve have a fragmented relationship
and then like we see the the
goldfish mysteriously get another fin
back and like in obviously it's because
it's a new goldfish but like i think
it's symbolically to represent like mark
accepting the different parts of his in
himself like steve and possibly jake
lockley and so like once he accepts that
and like tawarit the goddess of healing
allows him to heal himself mentally and
symbolically that way then he'll
probably just be like all right now i'm
fully myself and it's time to do real
moon nighting as uh you know my full
accepted self
depending if jake lockley is uh able to
be accepted right away because that dude
seems kind of uh ready to too ready to
roll too ready to kill uh but what do
you think um i think it's going to be
like if you consider the conflict of
this uh season has been mark versus
stephen right right mark with his other
alters like i wonder if like there could
be a total of six alters you know there
was like six is the big number in the
mcu it's a big number right uh six lines
for the eye of horus six priests that
were buried in the pharaoh's uh tomb
with him
six members of the og avengers six
infinity stones six sides to a hexagon
in the hex so i i think what we're gonna
see are the three
um uh forms of the altars you have mark
you have stephen and you have jake and
then whatever their powered up version
is you have the moon knight ceremonial
armor you have the mr knight armor and
then you have whatever jake armors up
into in that these six
will all have to work together the way
the avengers work together uh and the
way the infinity stones have to be
aligned
to fight their way out and they're each
gonna have different skill sets uh
different powers that all get uh that
all complement each other and work
together in specific ways and that's
going to be the way the conflict is
resolved in this uh series is that mark
isn't still going to have dissociative
identity disorder but he's going to
reach a certain balance with it where
they can agree who who takes the wheel
at any given moment right um so that way
he can kind of uh use his different
alters to his advantage now will that be
problematic in some ways maybe
that might be problematic but this is
just steven's story yeah mark's story at
the end of the day i don't think they're
saying this is meant to be a poster
representation of everyone usdid uh
because obviously everyone who has the
id is not also possessed by any egyptian
deity yeah obviously
it's very rare for that to happen uh but
i really like how you brought that up
because it reminds me of that teen
titans episode with raven and like she
had to like embrace for the different
parts of her personality and she was
like wearing different colors to
represent the different parts of her
personality i just think it's really fun
and cool that they're doing that i hope
that happens like in that example yeah i
don't know i guess we'll see we'll see
um i'm not saying they have to do it
this way or this is the only cool way to
do it i just that seems to be one way
the show could go uh and i think like uh
meanwhile
not in this underworld i i think it's
gonna require layla to find khan shu's
ushabti and smash it or whatever it is i
don't know it's just a matter of
smashing or seeing some other kind of
incantation reading some passage from
the book of the dead translating the
scarab and reading some other passage on
it um there's all kinds of like
things that she can say or do to to free
the spirit or maybe she just really
threatens to five any ad members she's
like i'm gonna expose your internet
search history
i got your text messages don't mess with
me read every receipt
everywhere
well uh the breakdown is coming folks
it's coming later today so keep an eye
out for that but that's where we'll
leave things this episode of inside
marvel i cannot see i cannot wait to see
what comes next don't forget to check
out our great merch options at
directorsmerch.com uh follow me at eavos
follow mt mastertainment subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast thanks for watching later
skaters latest skaters love you guys
you